[Music]
what do you think well it's uh it's not
the kind of music that Old Willie
Shakespeare here used to
write oh well SP do something
intelligent
B
[Music]
you want to read
why have you uh had an experience with
that 12 years at YouTube I've seen some
pretty awful
you had any experience with
that you mean
personally
yeah yeah I have
it's never
good my boss at YouTube was an
alcoholic meaning
drunk she used to come in hammered
looking to wail on somebody so I'd
provoke her hoping she wouldn't go after
the smaller
[Music]
channels
kids full of puberty
blockers YouTube execs gave us the
choice to blur every face in the whole
video or said we could just skip the
time and have it outright removed said
choose well I'd have to go with just
removing it there Vanna we went with
blurring all the
faces
why because them that's why and
your account received a heart strike
anyway he
yeah so what is it Crowder's got some
kind of rebellion complex or something
some kind of a general problem with
authority is that why I have to put a
half asian lawyer on retainer full-time
I didn't know you had yeah well I did
you want to talk about it
no hey
Crowder I don't know a
lot but you see
this all this
the demonetization the heart strikes the
video removals the
policies it's not your
fault yeah I know that look at me
son it's not your
fault I know no it's not your
fault I know no no you
don't it's not your
fault it's not your
fault it's not your fault
it's not your
fault it's not your fault with me not me
not you don't it's not your
fault it's not your
[Music]
fault for Content like this and more
join MB today for 8 $9 annually or go
mugas for n bucks a month lwith cr.com
mugclub
[Music]
[Applause]
hoo
[Music]
it is your fault it's your fault that
it's your fault that you're here you're
still here we appreciate let me give you
the rundown really quickly today we have
an update on Chipawa Falls uh the school
that we discussed yesterday in the
wouldbe school shooting uh spoiler alert
they of course attacked the messenger
and they did exactly what we thought
right on time uh no the parents were
never at risk but now we Yours Truly has
put them at risk we're also going to be
talking about uh former Vice President
Joe Biden some people call him sitting
president some people call him former
Vice I call him former vice
president respect the office uh he's
holding Americans hostage right now over
the Border live today if there's an
update right now it is 10:14 a.m.
eastern uh the Supreme Court is going to
be hearing the arguments in the Trump uh
ballot case you know this is from the
Colorado Court moving up and everyone
here is sick there's the Bubonic plague
oh also just because you'll know who is
in third chair we have uh some clips
from an all female SWAT team in their
training that's really just because no
no no no it's it's a competition it's a
competition this was the best of the
best of the best sir so I yes exactly
trained to eat things it would make a
billy go
puke you're going to put that many women
in a SWAT team there's one thing you'll
need a good supply of body bags just
watched it or tampons uh which by the
way he's sometimes uh Nick depal you
know I'm going to go third chair first
in third chair
today cuz it's new song he wanted the
new song he gave me crap about it
yesterday he's going to be uh in uh Red
Bank New Jersey May 11th count bayy
Center go see him the OG one of the well
funniest man alive I think certainly as
far as standup comedy and so with the
other people in this industry and his
show was on Mud Club 5:00 P p.m. Eastern
Nick depalo how are you sir what do you
mean as far as stand up how about sketch
and I can do all kinds of acatic
oh sorry I thought you gave acatic
I thought I I thought I gave you a nice
intro it was it was fun can I ask you a
question no did all that work on that
new song and you just talked
over the well we we didn't want
people to go to sleep Nick oh suck a
dick we just had to bleep It Anyway Nick
and then he doesn't have a song
number two Captain Morgan how are you
sir I'm
relapsing thank you for that audio I
appreciate that Crystal math no no no no
sickness
I made you feel better though yeah yeah
you did you made me feel better cuz I I
skipped the gym it has been a week since
I've this body has seen activity and I
thought I'm going to relapse if I do
this and then half the office again
called in sick so I'm holding it
together all right today especially it's
probably already happened with the uh
the rewind of the Goodwill Hunting but
if at any point you see
this head on over to uh Rumble
especially as we do the update from
chipa Falls and you want to know watch
the show it's a live show weekdays 10:00
a.m. eastern check the references and
then
leave let me ask you this you're a
parent where do you on up after
yesterday we have received uh emails
contacts from well over 50 parents who
are grateful um who are livid about what
happened yeah there in Chipawa Falls but
the media is not going to really discuss
them local media has they've done a
somewhat effective job we don't have
okay I was just checking to make sure
speakers aren't on but it's my ears are
blocked because of the AIDS all
right so Mr dip this is right up your
alley I don't know if you you were uh if
you've seen this yet Mr dip but I
actually looked around who the
oh that's me that's the other Mr
dip you need to adjust your headphones
is that no why is there a pillow here
because some people like lower back
support do you want the lower back
support I can I can put it under your
bed we' got lower back supp I remove
the no he's upset because he doesn't
have the donut ring for his I could use
I like Valley grapes hanging out
of my
ass they're back I had them removed 10
years ago they're back with a
vengeance make a movie about it
so speaking of the authorities uh uh
Chile decided to send there and this is
the thing um I don't want uh and you can
comment below I don't want women on SWAT
teams I don't want uh women in General
on the front lines of combat I don't
want women uh in in in in firefighting
if it requires you know lifting heavy
things as a general in is in situations
where it's a matter of life and death I
want the most qualified person
especially as it relates to their
physicality
so that's just my opinion M here is
something that is not my opinion the
women of Chile decided to uh do this
this SWAT
competition well actually Chile decided
to send their all woman team to an
international SWAT comp comption yeah
this the best of the best yes of the
best and that's the other problem
they're always
Chile now like those
peruvians a dirty here is here is uh how
it went and Hint it went exactly how you
think
[Music]
R and here we
go they jog out they're wading and here
we go two teams from the
EMS
the wet Bandits did better three team
members
stranded in the middle of that ice
bath ah what do we do water will be a
little bit you're going need some that
work
woman's kick her right at L4
L5
oh even three team members listen to
this
listen even the splash sounds weak well
forget about getting
wet the uh the violations the major she
has a decision to makeing weapons in the
water just hangs there Noe not going in
and then that's illegal yeah I'm sure
you'll do that during an emergency I'm
sure she's good at reading Miranda
rights retrieved
wow and of she thought it was a zipline
into the pool as a
ride it's like an episode of double dare
she's like they realize this isn't about
swimming on the Z line they become wet
hands become wet everything becomes why
she going back under oh fix have to get
no you have to get the Firearms oh
that's a penalty if you lose your weapon
okay one
[Music]
minut I just the combination of lower
body weight and upper body strength it's
about the ratio that's right you know
it'd be like Neil Cavuto doing a zipline
that shredded God yes it's like the
statue of David personified now in all
fairness small penis that was a tough
obstacle cold in there no but I but hey
just to be clear I really like Neil
kabudo I I was just trying to think of
someone who would have a tough time
doing a zipline it's not fair okay all
fairness is a tough I'm sure the men
struggled as well
and they're up andun just look at the
running just the difference right there
just the
difference biological differences men
right they're designed to go hunt hunt
the Buffalo and and other the women
their hips are better for birthing all
the way AC there we go all right think
of that run in the high hand versus the
waddle they should be washing dishes in
that
pool and if they do it poorly you send
in the mail SW team exactly
right see how the fellas just took to it
I I just I mean come on look and that's
the best of the best hilarious in the
entire country now can I ask you a
question was that a test they're already
they're already they're competing that's
the competition that's the competition
but they were already cops or whatever
the yeah yeah yeah they are they
are the SWAT team if you call and
they're like we're sending the old
female SWAT team it's like H I'm going
to die yeah don't bother I'll put this G
on my mouth can you send Police Academy
the actors from police academ Bob C I
really like the guy that can do every
noise gutenberg's not doing much just
send him out my God please and also the
women's SWAT team though of course
Hollywood already purchased the rights
they do have a new film coming
out well that seems hey oh my God you
guys are sexist well here's the thing
though too this has real world
consequences think think about this for
a second okay if I am a violent man okay
if I am a man on my size on PCP uh and
I've already decided that I'm fine with
assaulting women and my choice is go to
jail for years right or beat the ever
loving crap out of one of those it's an
easy Choice I'm going to beat the crap
out of them don't take that out of
context sounds like my
honeymoon with who was in the SWAT
outfit was it I of your business okay
I'm sorry I didn't mean to cross any
lines
Nick and here's the thing Dei applies to
everything and you can comment below
we've had women on the show who are
sergeants going yeah I can't deal with
the women they send me now I can't yell
at them also they don't have to do
pull-ups they can just do dead hangs it
the fake victim culture creates real
victims I don't know like the person who
needs to be rescued by a by a stron
heady police officer oh instead I have
you all right I'm about to get
raped so here's Dei uh of course being
applied across the board you have it
with police you have it with firefighter
you have it uh with the military as seen
by our stretchy maternity flight suits
and here's even Delta touting
Dei
slave slave
Slave oh yes well thank you uh for
having a priority straight while Boeing
has doors falling
off yeah they're rehearsing and Dei that
exact EI is yes you guessed it in
firefighting from the International
Association of Fire Chiefs oh my gosh
and uh just save me just save me or fly
the plane I don't care who it is and you
know here's a thing too A lot of people
they'll say sexist but let's be hon here
for a second this is also why men don't
like watching women's MMA in general we
don't like watching women get beaten up
and though we're not watching that in
the competition we know it's an
eventuality it's an inevitability she's
going to be beaten to a pulp has to go
to the tool belt and shoot somebody yes
of course yes in which case you don't
like UFC cheick on cheick typic well let
me give you an example as to why not my
stomach turned when I watched cyborg
fight I think we have a clip beat up Jan
finny now this was not like a male MMA
match where it was itive this was a
female who clearly was walking human pin
cushion whose technique was gorilla
smash with basically a part-time nurse I
don't know Jan finny who was a last
minute replacement getting and it looks
very much just she's holding on to
Cyborg's Foot Right like ah and just
she's
going that's the whole fight and you're
sit going stop the fight here's a clip
oh she goes down and just holds on they
bring it man when these girls fight
they bring it all she wants wissow to
stop the
[Applause]
fight they don't even know how
to think they may she just keeps
punching her like all right fight to be
stopped survives this round wow hats off
to and no that's why I don't like
watching it well if you had a male ref
he would have jumped in he probably
would have this girl women hate women so
she was probably enjoying that she
probably that girl stole a lipstick
before the fight exactly the ref's
lipstick I mean yes exactly I mean
whatever it's that was the problem with
that clip it was three women in a cage
yeah there was no man to be like all
right you two come on now pick them up
like they're drunk let's go that's what
you want you got to jump in there you
got to jump in there and it's not
because men want to see women hurt it's
because we don't want to see women hurt
and sure you're watching a competition
it looks like an episode of wipe out
it's funny it's you know American not
Ninja Warrior but eventually that woman
is going to be beaten up they shouldn't
be in that job but hey it's not just
about them it's about you when the SWAT
team shows up or when the officer shows
up can we just look as it deals with Dei
can we just go back when it comes to
life and death can we go back to hiring
the best people for the job is that a
possibility is that too much to ask is
that what is uh what is happening that's
not what seriously what's happening oh
for the what's happening we having a
glitch hey to man sorry uh we're we're
triing a woman on Tri C her why well cuz
she she doesn't know what she's doing
well well she's she's woman get her out
of here out of here cool man get her out
no Bale B and she's laughing about it
yeah go no
yes
boo boo go boo
boo doesn't even she doesn't even know
how to run the tricaster I mean a woman
can run the tricaster but that not that
one not that one come back here with a
hey sorry about that wa do it again do
better thanks Tim Tim okay let's go to
Chipawa Falls here I'm sorry you had to
see that but just rest assured she's a
horrible
person I mean she's not just an up she's
on top it's
okay hates Jews she hates Jews no it's
fake news fake news hates Jews hates
Jews by the way did you see that TMZ is
going after Shane Gillis again because
he's going to host SNL and they're
bringing up an old clip of him referring
to a story where someone says the NW and
like Shen Gill says the nword so we'll
talk about that next week oh my talk
about it tonight I they keep going after
they keep going after this guy it's like
just it's very they they put together a
highlight reel from his podcast and he's
a he's not even a dangerous comic he's a
smart funny yep he's not even dangerous
no and he's actually pretty sharp like
he he knows history pretty damn well
absolutely I didn't know that much about
him till lately and I did some I
like the guy the guy yeah the guy's
funny so they fire from SNL they say all
right we'll have him come in and host
and then sure enough front page TMZ
believe he first yes we who who's
staging the hit that's what you always
ask oh TMZ oh is it New York Post is it
vanity is it variety Vanity Fair the sun
take a guess I told you they called my
house after the little bar scuffle oh
really yeah that's how I know it's
you I haven't heard from TMZ in
years pushing pushing it's like punch B
and the
m
all
right so yesterday we broke this story
uh about a middle school in Wisconsin
Right chipa Falls that they covered up a
Manifesto potential school shooter okay
uh we learned about it through a viewer
on the tip line and uh we requested we
put in a foyer request uh with the
police department uh to receive the
report now let me recap it for you the
administration knew about this we read
the report yesterday it was graphic it
was incredibly detailed as far as dates
times locations Plan B is for dates
times locations wish lists types of
weapons to be used how to create bombs
where to purchase Bombs all of this was
in the manifesto to be clear the
administration knew the school board
knew the police knew but they don't have
the authority to notify parents so just
to be clear they did their job in
investigating the parents were never
told that was the story and of course it
would directly affect the safety of the
parents to refresh your memory or those
who missed it uh here's a very brief
clip from what we read uh from the
actual police report yesterday on air I
want to kill here's the target every old
man and woman who has claim to the
father Son and Holy Spirit by chopping
their heads off and putting them
on a stick to show there is no God Only
Human Nature I will kill the most people
I can by using explosives that I will
make myself Al he problems don't even
know how to correct that one that I face
will be worth it after I kill all the
jocks and all those
preppy shitthe headed girls they
need to die and they will go burn in
hell now we have an update the
superintendent released a statement uh
riddled with at best misstatements most
likely lies just to be clear and we have
received well over 50 uh emails uh
correspondents from family member
parents saying thank you and they are
incredibly concerned just to be clear
now of course national news coverage
they're not going to cover that but the
local media did do some of their due
diligence and actually showed at least a
couple of parents who were calling for
officials uh to resign or be fired he
Shannon the parents I spoke with tonight
say their concerns stem from the lack of
immediate communication shocked
overwhelmed and disbelief were three
words one parent used to describe the
emotions he felt after finally getting
the word of the incident months later
his son is a chipa Falls middle schooler
other areas of concern news 18 heard
from parents include the school
district's leadership those I spoke with
tonight calling for new leadership to
step up I have the full faith that
they're going to they're going to take
care of these students
but the leadership I think is falling
apart and I would like to see the
superintendent either resign or be
removed in my opinion the ones that
failed to tell the families should be
fired and by the way I'm so glad that it
was the parents that they were I was
like please don't be the averies or some
guy who just like there's n words at the
school so like okay you were like is the
if the media is going to cherry pick
like I don't want my kid in school in
the first place go Crowder woo
like okay what if Wisconsin yeah yeah
they're going to shoot up to school
yeah so this story by the way reached
tens of millions of people um and uh
we're incredibly grateful if you have
more tips if you live in uh the town or
your children go to the school send your
email to lwc tips protonmail.com if you
want more investigative journalism
consider joining mug Club 89 annually $9
you can go mug list month to month okay
really appreciate it none of this
happens without you to be clear it's not
possible and over 50 parents are
grateful and touched not by just what
what you have supported and allowed to
happen yeah so the school of course
responded in a very very predictable
fashion well actually you know you you
you said it yesterday basically you said
that they would try to flip this and
make this about you and so kind of
brings us you called
it come let Zar tell you more I the next
pitch ball right past the flight we're
going to win the game I
guarantee
by the way you know Babe Ruth apparently
didn't actually do that I think he did
no apparently he was just like
stretching his arm I don't think so yeah
he called it and then he popped up to
the catcher and the kid died yes when he
was hitting a 50 m hour fast ball with a
cigarette in his
mouth hey it makes it even harder to get
it out of the park you can see the crabs
crawling out of his oh my God his
pants what's he doing just craing I want
to be with the people
he actually pointed to distract the
audience so he could scratch his
nuts ever do that one when you're peeing
actually know he was pointing to get rid
of the one black guy in the crowd he's
like hey I think he had black and
they're like let's get one on our team
well this changes the game all right I'm
going by his nose so we did I guess I
did call it so let's go back to then
yesterday and this is not to be
self-aggrandizing this is just so that
you can see that you yourself can use
this framework going forward the left is
very predictable dishonest people are
very predictable I believe we have the
clip from how we said this would go down
starting yesterday we have an entire
investigative team here uh imagine you
the parent trying to get this
information right there it's done you're
not going to get a hold of anybody
there's never going to be any
accountability it's the same thing you
know we discussed this with Carri Lake
when she recorded someone trying to
effectively bribe her right yeah the
attack then became how could you record
somebody well hold a second if this
person is doing something dishonest if
there are actual victims because of the
the crimes or misdeed Deeds that you
were perpetrating think about that for a
second yeah it becomes about the
reporting it becomes about the messenger
so let's go to
now uh chip Falls a superintendent Jeff
Holmes released a statement regarding
the report and boy it just makes it
worse these people just I mean I don't
know if we need to ship them
shovels they need to put the shovels
down stop digging you guys did a
phenomenal job right up until not
notifying the parents yes exactly we we
should all be taking a Victory lap and
applauding the system working until you
drop the ball here yeah and there are
some other details too that we wanted to
go over reiterate or maybe that we
didn't specify yesterday that
specifically have to do with the danger
um the children were were put in so
let's go through one of their claims
okay in this uh paper which is released
or statement which you can read at
lc.com with a link in the description um
they said that students were never in
danger okay so this man says I need to
State clearly and unequivocally that the
district determined our students were
not in jeopardy at any time during these
events here's the truth this student was
danger Dangerous enough to be suspended
immediately and then expelled 5 weeks
later so let's put that timeline
together October 23rd right he suspended
or she he Z they according to the report
suspended December 6th the student was
expelled think about that for five weeks
that's the danger zone what if I have a
daughter who's pretty who this person
was targeting what if my child is a
Christian for 5 weeks us as parents we
have no idea this person is there and
has has an Amazon wish list with Lil
bastards toolkit we all have potassium
nitrate and frozen orange juice yeah and
our Amazon Wish carts don't we yeah I
that that's the time period where you
think okay if if something's going to
happen it's most likely to happen here
this person's kind of been found out and
this is the highest risk to the students
and for them to come back out and double
down on that say hey they were never at
risk at any time it's like guys come on
how do you not see that and can someone
pull the quote just the one quote where
from the statement they said these quasi
media Outlets who are putting actually
creating more danger through
sensationalizing this sorry our bad it's
our fault you know what admonish me
admonish me and admonish the 50 plus
parents I'm willing to bet that it racks
up to hundreds before the end of the day
how dare you think that you should know
for 5 weeks there was someone purchasing
trench coats frozen orange juice Annie
freeze potassium nitrate and saving up
to get a $2,700 shotgun to shoot up your
children how dare you think that you
should know that here's another claim
that they make and this is one that they
refute themselves it's so dishonest they
can't keep it straight they said there
was no unusual police presence which is
why no the parents weren't told if you
remember that just a simple question
like why would you let parents know
about less credible things when you had
something that was seems more credible
to me based on the conversation I have
and you wouldn't let parents know about
that I'm just just honestly that's my
main
question okay yeah and and I I
understand that right and and I I get
your your your your conversation that it
seems more credible um you know I would
say with with the swatting instance and
things like that like you know there
were um sometimes police officers that
showed up to our building and so forth
and so um you know obviously we we let
people know that there was not there was
not anything going on everybody was safe
everybody was okay in this situation we
you know we we got to it right away we
handled it really quickly and um and
again we we felt that there was no
credible threat to you know to our our
staff or our student at the time or
anything like that I love watching Nick
when we play these clips because as a as
a comic he gets so mad like he's he's
going to get another
hemorrhoid
impossible imagine if that's your kid at
that school seriously can I ask you a
question I yeah do we know if this kid
was trans or not we have no idea we
don't know and what how old was the kid
no idea Middle School age middle scho I
was going to say Middle School all right
yeah Middle School I'm not sure what it
is so they said there was no there's no
added police presence so we didn't need
to notify the parents here's the truth
or which which one of them is true I
don't know according to the parents last
night superintendent Holmes stated the
district maintained an ongoing dialogue
with our guidance counselors and
supervising teachers the district also
consulted with local law enforcement
officials and maintained a police
presence as well the police report also
detailed increased presence so we didn't
need to notify because it wasn't
increased police presence and by the way
we did everything responsibly because we
increased police
presence that that was the whole re for
not notifying the parents was that there
was not seen by the public just read it
like that nothing was seen by the public
that we would have to explain and so we
didn't notify parents because that's
there was increased police presence
before and if he says no that's not what
I said I said we maintained police
presence so you kept the one officer on
campus and you're using that as a
justification for taking additional
measures that doesn't make any sense at
all either way it doesn't work it yeah
yeah you're playing a you're using the
safety of these children as a PR cudle
as a c here like yeah hold on the
children are fine because we say one
thing and then we did another they're
fine because there are fewer police
they're fine because they increased
police how are these children safer and
how are the parents how are the parents
being informed how are they capable of
helping and protecting their children if
you do not inform them none of this is
consistent I'm sure they probably have
some really skillful uh PR Consultants
who suck so yeah here's another claim
from the administration that the school
was just following protocol that's
always great I was just following
orders so am I that's usually what you
know if it were an action film so they
say the situation was identified and
monitored student safety was accounted
for the district intervened and the
matter was resolved without incident in
this situation however we determined
that it did not rise to the level
requiring a public announcement and that
making an announcement might be
inflammatory generating new issues
concerning staff and student safety no
no okay here's the thing the truth
nothing in their prot required them to
keep parents in the dark and actually
would fly in the face of standard
protocols that they in fact enforce let
me tell you why okay let me put a fine
point on this as to when they because
they because they say this right here
they say concerning Staff All
right we have 50 plus emails from
parents right now okay you know the
school has hundreds and that doesn't
normally happen does not people that
have done this before usually you get a
handful of parents that'll reach out in
situations like this they say
overwhelming support right now so you
might get some an parents out there who
go what hold on a second where did this
where did this student
learn the Communist Manifesto KL Marx
where would they be encouraged to learn
that wait a second where would my child
learn to hate Christians and pretty
people and traditional uh here's your
teacher that's why they don't want you
asking questions where did my kid How
could a child be radicalized like that
not because of some YouTube rabbit hole
that doesn't exist because of what
they're learning in school to be clear
that's why they don't want you
digging guarantee you if you dig into
what's being taught in the classrooms
you'll hear some of it that's why they
that's why they don't want to see what
happens in Florida happen in any other
state they have your children for eight
hours a day minimum so again the truth
that nothing requires them to keep the
parents in the dark matter of fact
here's uh one of their uh policies or
from their protocol it says this is
titled sorry communicating with the
public the superintendent shall assure
that the public is adequately informed
about the condition and direction of the
district would a child who is currently
on suspension for 5 weeks with a plot a
date a date that takes place during the
suspension mind you with nothing to lose
and a
cart full of raw materials to build
bombs I certainly would think that
qualifies Charlie yeah do me a favor go
back to the bottom of his statement just
up a little bit there talk about new
threats right it said if if we you know
issues concerning right there so
inflammatory generating new issues
concerning staff and student safety no
the issues would not be new the issues
existed yes the parents just didn't know
they existed that's not a new issue I
understand what you're saying that maybe
this causes a new situation potentially
the problem is you didn't address a
situation that already existed yeah you
just hope that the parents never found
out about it that everybody went on
their merry way you guys again we should
be taking a Victory lap you guys that
the first part of that statement was
accurate you did a great job avoiding a
tragedy making sure something didn't
happen and then you didn't follow up and
say hey parents by the way this happened
right maybe be aware of what's going on
with your students right now be careful
let's talk about this you have to go
public with this stuff you have to tell
us and you can do it in a way that
doesn't reveal the identity of the
people involved which is what they also
said in the letter like I'm sorry that
we can't tell you things about the
identity of the people that are involved
in this let me ask you this let me I'm
sorry but let me ask you this is this
would be shooter now homeschool only or
are they going to another school because
if you they're recruiting people to be
an assistant shooter just to be just to
be clear if do the kids know at the next
school do the parents know at the next
school that this is a kid who had a plot
and a date in graphic detail to execute
fellow students or is is this child only
allowed to stay at home now hey that's
relevant yeah is it child getting the
help that they need that's what we want
well I want the child to get the help
they need but I also don't want them to
be a risk to other children ex hey this
person wants to kill pretty girls my
daughter's pretty hey this person wants
to kill Christians I have a pretty
Christian daughter where's this person
who wants to kill my daughter they're
suspended when was the date the shooting
was supposed to happen tomorrow and you
didn't think you should fill me in on it
here's another policy from them policy
o4 it's titled treatment of community
stakeholders the superintendent shall
cultivate an organizational culture that
treats parents and Community
stakeholders with respect dignity and
courtesy and they will sustain an
organizational culture that reasonably
includes people in decisions that affect
them let's bring up that quote that I
was talking about uh where they said
this is just
sensationalism uh and these quasi media
Outlets it's actually your next over
okay good um just to be clear I look
we're we're we we of course expect it
there're saying that all of you the 50
parents who reached out to us I don't
know how many reached out to that you're
stupid they're saying this could
actually just uh this could uh make
things more inflammatory and you don't
think the parents are adult enough you
think that they're going to be fooled by
some quasi media hack or do you think
it's something that actually matters
they're not saying that we're stupid
they're saying that you the parents are
stupid did these parents get treated
with respect let's move on to see if you
treat them with respect now today when
they're concerned another claim that
they make our report was full of
misinformation the report mind you that
you can all read publicly verb the whole
show in context the police report which
we read remember I said we're reading it
I'm sorry this is boring but I'm going
to read it in its entirety because
they're going to say that we are
misinforming you or we edited it out of
context you can watch it read in its
entirety or read it in its entirety they
have no respect for you they're saying
the police report is misinformation yes
pretty much so this is what they say as
an initial matter it is forunate when
irresponsible quasi media personality
sensationalize these situations their
comments are not accurate and
potentially dangerous oh boy this parade
of misinformation provides good cause
for me to share how we approach these
situations the truth he full of
full of
the reporting again came directly
from a source in chipa wa Falls the
official police report that we have made
publicly available and at no no point in
time when we were in communication or
reach did the superintendent Holmes cite
what we said as far as misinformation
point to an example this is my challenge
all right I'll put it on the line
okay superintendent
Holmes if you can point to the
misinformation from our reading of the
report and what we have provided
publicly the references if you can find
that let me put it this way if you can't
find it you resign which is what the
parents want anyway if you can find it I
will quit this show forever don't do it
don't I need the
cash never mind the kids I'm starving if
you can find how we altered the police
report any of the facts that have been
provided publicly and by the way that
applies to hey all of you have the
references fact check us you can check
them yesterday check them today if you
can find where we altered edited lied
about misrepresented the reports the
facts not talking about jokes in the
show you find it you call me on it I
will quit this show forever if you can't
find it you resign and hey let's be
honest you're just going to move on to
another
school they'll Shuffle you around like
priests so like like like this video if
you think that challenge is
fair the the manifesto that's why I
asked the age it sounds like the writing
of somebody old than Elementary School
uh Middle School a middle okay either
way yeah you know what I mean it sounds
like a high school could be could be
that you know they could the middle
school it is in an area of Wisconsin
where you know a lot of them have
repeated the grades three four times H
that's unfair that's that's come on
those are backer fan don't yeah yeah I
particularly like it when they wear food
on their heads yes jez oh cheee why
identify with you brother cheese my gosh
I have family in Wisconsin I love them
dearly I do too but they quite literally
will never answer a call if the Packers
are
on Packers Packers there's nothing wrong
with love oh that Favre he's coming back
he's coming back he's going to win it
he's got a second
wind no no we lose we lost Aaron Rogers
we got Jordan love though so you know I
don't know who that is is there a new
quarterback I only know about Brett
Favre because he wears really cool jeans
no so yeah Wrangler I think that's a
fair look I think it's a fair magnets
skinny
jeans you know I see these jeans here
you know they're modern and but they're
too comfortable can you give me one
without stretch I'd like the dungies
that they wore in Cool Hand Luke while
they're working on the railroad can you
give me those they chape your thighs
when it gets above 80 yeah they double A
sandpaper yes thank you
yeah you're right though what the the
big question here is What Becomes of
this kid where does he go what do they
do with him here's what they need to do
kid gets help and every single person
who is at risk is notified yeah by the
way some of those things are redacted
there are people named with greater
specificity keep in mind and we're
protecting the identities of those
people in other words if I were to say
hey I'm going to shoot Josh guess what
Josh's Dad should probably be notified
just so you know there was a kid who
said he's going to shoot your kid oh
when five weeks ago where's he been uh
suspended with not a lot to do a lot of
time on his hands and apparently a
lengthy Amazon wish list includes
potassium nitrate see you let talk about
this yeah his
freezer had 18 gallons of orange
juice some pulp a lot of vitamin C
some speaking of which I just picked a
name out of my where is Josh I didn't
see him this morning Josh I think he uh
he went to another screen test he he did
text me oh he's been busy lately he's
been really swinging the bat do we let's
go check it out no let's see it
[Applause]
where in the world is
Josh hey hey how's it going I'm Josh
great so you're auditioning for the
whisper in Field of Dreams go ahead
whenever you're ready all
right okay cut cut I'm sorry it's way
too low we couldn't hear a thing you can
actually whisper
oh I was whispering I was just trying to
be as quiet as possible you know doing a
real whisper here uh but you guys do
things your way so uh here we goes uh
one
second still can't hear you could you go
just a little bit louder okay hey
way see my dick what are you
doing it's a Whisper Song by the
ying-yang twins okay they're rappers
you're way way off this is for the voice
of the cornfield the voice of the
cornfield like the corn is talking
no what do you mean like voice of the
Corn like what's it saying like make me
into whiskey you know what I'm talking
about right no the corn this guy knows
what I'm talking about right s guy yeah
dude the corn isn't talking me and you
this voice is coming from the field okay
it's coming from the field uh and I'm
whisper you sure I should be whispering
cuz what if it what if they can't hear
me like what if why am I Whispering what
if the wind comes no one's going to be
able to hear me am I trying to hide am I
hiding from someone like no no it's just
trying to find my motivation here man
like am I scarecrow like what's the deal
you're Whispering
Whispering okay just Whispering out of
the Corn so what what kind of whisper do
you want me to like what kind of
attitude you want me to like be caringly
you caringly whisper no not necessarily
okay well I think I know what you want
give me one second let me get ready I
think I got what you want okay this is
Careless
Whisper
[Music]
[Applause]
cut in the world is
JN we thank him for his service but he's
going to need absolutely swing but I've
never seen Field of Dreams really what I
don't think I have either I've never
seen League I've never seen League of
Their Own either I've never seen hoers I
don't care about hoers so much what I
don't care about it so
much lumpy hoers lumpy Kevin cner movies
you got to see Field of Dreams Field of
Dreams is great no you don't yes it did
comment below do I really need to see
Field of Dreams is it a requirement I
saw I saw a porn field of wet dreams yes
well my goodness that was also the SWAT
competition if you open it never mind
oh I stopped because I heard it in my
head before I said it be ashamed of
yourself what's the best PA title
ever I don't know if that I want to know
but I do searching for Barbie's
fissure it's funny that you say that
best
I I always go to the anal Fishers if I'm
making gay jokes because it's medical
and it was a it was actually TI I almost
Shi myself up is a
[Music]
genius
met bundle of sticks this was six seven
years ago hey by the way there are only
a few weeks left uh to win the Ford
Raptor or $10,000 at cop.com oh and
sorry that's right it's one prize yeah
it's one prize one prize yeah how do I
win that Ford Raptor $10,000 cop.com and
you can get these fight likee hell
shirts I think it's insider trading if
you I don't think we're allowed to but I
plan on quitting I'll get you I'll get
you a base model Ford oo Ford Pinto yes
nice sit down more 19 get home he a nice
Gremlin a blaze in his
driveway and by the where it's uh the
count bisy Center in Red Bank New Jersey
May uh May 11th in uh Red Bank is it red
B yeah May Mother's Day weekend bring
her out we'll put a hole in her
and by the
way bring that back up bring that back
up are you killing mother's in-law is no
but I tell you what he is killing the
David Blaine headshot game well I'm glad
you picked something that made me look
so young for Christ sake what am I a
Cancer Victim there
could be look like Barney
Miller pick a card is this I got a
million head
shots that looks like an x-ray you sent
us two though CT skin that's my
management I didn't send you should you
should have been tipped off when they
pumped you full of of iodine for your
head
shot are you sure this is how they do
shots going in a tunnel all right you
can see my oxygen tank in the background
I need one right now you everyone he's
laughing like eth mer the last four days
you're
laughing so just really quickly update
on the Supreme Court right now what
they're doing is that if you've seen CNN
you can bring that up on the lower third
ler part of the screen they're basically
playing the audio of the arguments and
so just to to kind of sum it up right
now there's a lot of argument about
whether the states can do something
independently and a lot of concern about
that so the the kind of the more
conservative leaning justices seem to
want no part of doing that so far and
the liberal justices are not taking the
other side they just seem very tepid
about it in their questioning and their
responses so so far it doesn't look very
good for Donald Trump to be removed from
the ballot in States because of the
insurrectionist meaning it looks good
for America it does look good for
America to have him on the ballot we'll
see how it goes got a question there no
he just he reframed I forgot he's got so
many indict he cut you out from under
the it's like he's leg kicking a child I
didn't I didn't no no I I I couldn't uh
I couldn't remember which one this was
for those of you who don't know we found
out yesterday on mug club that Gerald is
a sociopath he leg kicked a fellow
student causing nerve damage and shoved
a girl into concrete because she was
beating him in a foot race and I split
her chin yeah and he said he was kind of
a bully I well just for a minute that
doesn't make what makes him a psychopath
he hasn't done anything worse than that
since third grade oh he has told he's
just not telling us wait till I tell you
his treatment of animals and I told him
it is your fault it is your fault by the
way something else too I don't know if
we can pull it but a CNN it would have
been this morning around uh gosh
8 sorry 750 Central so 850 Eastern the
what the wig guy no no no not that that
was funny though but they were talking
about the Supreme Court And the reporter
said and this case you know we'll
determine if Donald Trump can be on the
ballot or not which very likely will
determine the next president they said
that three times on CNN wow that tells
you what they're basically saying if
Donald Trump is the candidate he's going
to win they may try and argue no I was
saying if Donald Trump's the candidate
he's going to lose despite all polls
showing that he would win so their
argument would hold no water they said
that on CNN where wait hold a second did
I hear that right and I I had to rewind
it I did they believe the left believes
that if Donald Trump is on the ballot he
wins you can hit the comment do you
think so I really do at this pointless
something major changes I absolutely do
I think so that's how they meant it yeah
it could be the other way like you said
though no do they mean that if he's not
Nikki Haley is going to win but like you
said they're ignoring all the polls
Trump's ahead she's not going to win her
own home state she she lost Nevada to
any other candidate to literally any
other person so did Donald Trump to be
fair well he wasn't on the ballot I know
her her husband asked her to leave the
house yesterday and he's on deployment
he has no he has no
Authority you didn't ask her to leave
the house she beat him and placed him in
the Harry Potter closet under the stairs
he called from the Radio Shack that he
owns yes first
he kitchen you
where are you I'm met Blockbuster
yeah he's not Indian I'm sorry yeah I
have no idea but it's funny either way
all right let's go to former Vice
President Biden respect the office uh th
this is what's happening now with the
immigration Bill okay just so you know
of course the Senate hey I wonder who
called this uh said this was not going
to become law it got shut down right the
bipartisan as we were told border deal
on this vote the Y's are 49 the Nays are
50 three fifths of the Senators duly
Chosen and sworn not having voted in the
affirmative the motion is not agreed to
now keep in mind this was $118 billion
bill with 20 billion going to the Border
but uh 60 billion going to Ukraine how
about calling it the Ukraine
bill
yeah uh and of course like clockwork
what is happening the Democrats are
they're what they're blaming they're
saying this is bipartisan this is great
we need bipartisanship we need to come
to the center oh look no it's extreme
Republicans oh yeah and actually look
this you you you called this too
come let Zar tell you more I at the next
pitch ball right past the flag we're
going to win the game I
guarantee all right and again this isn't
to this isn't to say we're Geniuses this
is to say that the left the progressive
left is so predictable you too can Babe
Ruth even though he didn't do that Jud a
bu to left he did it again this is what
we said on
Monday but again the theme is bipartisan
it's by bipartisan it's bipartisan it's
great it's bipartisan it's bipartisan so
they can say look Republicans won't sign
the B the bipartisan Bill extremists MAA
basket of deplorables so stop with the
idea of saying I'm a compassionate
conservative we talked about that last
week stop saying I'm a moderate
conservative because if you don't go
along with the bill that provides
hundreds of billions of dollars to
Ukraine Israel to Wars that has nothing
to do by the way with immigration then
you'll be labeled an
extremist I do ni was about I'm sorry
it's tied to immigration this whole bill
right yeah of course well that even if
you you even if you exclude the
Ukrainian part and the and the Russia
money part yeah did you read the actual
5,000 a day are allowed in that's the
part that makes me more nuts than the
yeah none of it makes sense and all of a
sudden they care about the Border yeah
exactly right 2 Minutes to Midnight
these I it's I tell you what
they're sociopaths they accuse you of
doing exactly what it is that they are
doing that's the and by the way that is
you know this guy Andrew Breitbart he
talked about solinsky before anyone was
talking about him Rules for Radicals and
one of the rules is accuse the
opposition of doing exactly what it is
that you are doing that's a technique
that they use so they say oh you're
trying to turn this into a political
issue really with a border bill that's
60 billion for you $18 billion Bill and
only 20 billion to the Border really the
the the right-wing extremists are the
ones politicizing it so that was then
yesterday or sorry Monday where we
called it now the Democrats of course
the left they're blaming you MAA and by
the way said they by the way MAA is the
DI hire back or what Ma no that was me I
thought I didn't write any notes today
then I realized I threw them at the lady
oops
so the Democrats are right on Q blaming
Maga which is of course just a standin
for you if you disagree with this bill
for years they said they want to secure
the border now they have the strongest
border bill this country has ever SE
ever we're seeing statements about how
many oppose the bill now look I
understand former president is
desperately trying to stop this
bill not he's not interested in solving
the Border problem he he wants a
political issue to run against me I've
all but said that across the board no
one really denies that that I'm aware of
the American people want a solution that
puts an end to the empty political
rhetoric well there you have it former
Vice President Biden doesn't know
people and by the way I mean we we
talked about this too they we said okay
well put all those other things in their
own bill yeah right do it I believe and
research do me a favor and pull this up
I thought I saw over the last day or two
that they actually tried to pass a a a
bill funding Israel the 14 or something
billion dollars go to Israel failed
right failed on its own this is what
it's supposed to be on its own why would
Democrats not vote for it I thought you
wanted to send funding over there I
thought you were holding us over a
barrel because we didn't want to support
Israel we didn't want to support secure
the Border those are the things you
wanted to slide the Ukraine stuff in
without us looking yes but when we
separate it out you guys don't even want
it well this is what this is exactly
what uh of course they're doing they're
playing politics with while accusing you
of playing Pol hey I think that you I
think that people who were opposed to
this
bill I think that being opposed to $18
billion bill because only 20 billion
actually goes to the border and calling
it The Border bill or calling it the
immigration bill whatever label you want
to give it however it's being used you
know whatever colloquialism I'm trying
to remember the official name of the
bill but people were saying the not the
Border bill yeah they're saying the
Border Bill the Border Bill the
immigration Bill okay I think the people
saying but only 20 out of 118 billion go
I I think they're uh playing politics
less than you shoehorning it in that's
just my opinion though so after the bill
failed you just saw former Vice
President Biden and of course uh House
minority leader hakee Jeff who looks
like he's wearing a madame tusos hakee
Jeff mask said the exact same thing we
actually want to solve the
problem Republicans have been ordered by
Donald Trump not to
solve the challenge at the border but to
continue to play political games because
they want to use the Border as an
electoral issue in November and that's
going to backfire the Republicans
thought they set a border trap for
Democrats and they fell into it
themselves that kid from cousin sker is
still letting someone else pull the
strings that
is that's pretty good
remarkable his hand gestures weren't
timed with his emphasis on his voice I
know I know it's a black guy with no
rhythm I know he's completely offbeat
hard find that is hard to find explains
the light
skin he's got a white father and uh of
course but and we'll have to continue
this on mug Club in a little bit so if
you are not a member none of this
investigative journalism happens we do
an extra 100% of show every day Nick
depalo at 5 Alex Jones on Friday Hodge
twins Brian Callen no monetization on
YouTube so if you're watching the rumble
click that button you can join mug Club
U thank you so much for your support or
uh if you're on YouTube you can leave
but let's move on here to Democrat Nikki
Haley of course also slammed Republicans
I told them that if they would do this
that South Carolina would wrap their
arms around them and take care of them I
now officially work for you there is
nothing that you can need that we won't
make sure that we deliver sorry right
clip let's find the other right clip and
uh discuss this here Club he's going to
be count bayy uh theater theater in Red
Bank New Jersey May 11th thank you
Rumble YouTube piss off this is my club
[Applause]
time